john what's up brother how can i help
alrighty i'm just calling to talk
i'm just worried about my dad um i'm
worried mainly about his physical and
mental health
okay um starting with physical he's
obese probably pushing 400 pounds uh
we just got told he has high blood
pressure and
over over the last few years he's always
he's kept trying to go on diets and he
does well for about a month or two
and then we just can't get him to follow
along so i just want to
get your advice on how maybe to kind of
push him along and
kind of um inspire him or get him to
follow through and lose some weight
because i'm 22 and i'm
i'm kind of worrying at this point i
really want my kids to have grandkids
to have a grand father one day so yeah
that's a beautiful why man
good for you well first i want to shout
you out dude i appreciate you 11 year
old man
and to all the dads out there that are
eating or drinking or lonelying
or depressing or anxietying themselves
into tighter and tighter circles of
loneliness i want you to know
that whether they can say it or not in
the right way
your sons and daughters love you and
they miss you and they want you around
for their kids
they want you to be a grandad so john
thank you for verbalizing that in a way
that
so many people your age just don't know
how to do right
so um i've got
i've got two quick answers for you
before i just pop off and give those to
you
tell me about your dad um where did he
come from what does childhood look like
um how he explains it he had a really
fun and exciting childhood
a lot of a lot of friends growing up and
um
now we've kind of moved around a little
bit and we
i guess he doesn't have many friends he
has friends but he doesn't go to see him
um how's his marriage yeah is he still
married
uh oh yeah yeah him and my mom have a
great marriage
so what does your mom say about his
weight
um she tries to push him a lot and we
all talk to him about it
he says yeah i'm gonna get on it and
then he does it and he'll do great i
mean like
uh in the past two or three months he
lost probably
30 or 40 pounds and then and then it was
just like
it just stalled out and he's back to old
eating habits
and have you ever talked privately with
them not in a group but
just privately or driving somewhere or
you're having lunch together
and you just ask them hey dad tell me
what's going on man have you ever had
that conversation i know that's awkward
for a 22 year old to have with his old
man but
have you ever had that conversation it's
hard but i've been trying a lot more and
more
i've had a lot more opportunity to kind
of sit down with them
more often like taking long drives in
the car and whatnot
so we kind of talk about that stuff a
little more but
we don't really dive super into the y
it's that way
yeah but it's just always been that way
for as long as i can remember
okay so here's the math on this there's
a million reasons
why he has allowed himself to get to be
400 pounds
it could be it could be
medical issues it could be childhood
issues it could be relational issues
that you
as his son will never ever know he'll
never divulge those
it could be trauma that he's hanging on
to it could be that he just
loves life and he loves eating and he
doesn't care
right it could be a thousand things
you as an amateur um
investigator it's gonna end up driving a
wedge in your relationship if you try to
get to the root of some of those things
and you spend your energy trying to
figure out why okay
okay so here's the hard truth you can't
do anything
to make your dad
become a steward of his body to
want to be around for your grandkids
there's nothing you can do
i do have one hail mary that i think
would be an honorable thing for you to
do
that would give you some peace and that
would give him an opportunity to hear
you
and what i would recommend doing is i'm
going to add a
a a second step to something i recommend
everybody do right i'm always telling
people to write letters to somebody but
i want you to spend some time this
holiday season
by yourself and i want you to write a
letter to your dad and
really it's going to be a love letter i
want you to talk about how much you care
about him how much you
are so thankful that he ended up out of
all the people in the world he ended up
your old man
that he's the kind of guy that you can't
wait
for your kids that you don't even have
yet to meet him
i want it to be a love letter to your
old man one that is respectful
and kind and then here's the next step
and this is going to be hard okay are
you still with me
yes sir i want you to read it to him out
loud
okay i want you to do that in a private
setting i don't want you to embarrass
him
don't do it at dinner don't do it at a
public restaurant don't do it in front
of his
wife your mom or the other brothers and
sisters
i want you to tell him that you want to
have a private conversation with him
and that you love him and you'll never
fully know his full story
but you wrote him something that you
want him to hear
and then when it's over i want you to
hug him as tightly as you can
and then i want you to give him that
letter and tell him i love him i love
you
and i'm glad you're my dad and i'm
always here for you
and i hope you'll always be here for us
and then this is heartbreaking john but
that's the best you can do then you can
love him
nobody's ever changed a behavior in a
long-term positive direction by being
nagged
or complained into um
change right somebody has to look in the
mirror and say i'm worth it
and sometimes it's a it's a different
why sometimes it's a y for grandkid
sometimes it's a y
for the people around me usually though
that sort of lifestyle change especially
and i'm gonna frame this as an addiction
man addicts don't don't make good
long-term
long-term changes for other people they
have to decide
they are worth that change they have to
other people can help kickstart it man
but they've got to decide that john
and so do something magic and i'll any
any
son listening to this podcast to this
show
watching this on youtube
any of you you want to change your old
man's life you want you want to
fill his heart up write a letter and
then read it to him
write a letter and read it to him it'll
be the hardest thing you've ever done
it will be awkward and it will be magic
i still remember several years ago
i met my dad in a starbucks and
i just had to look him in the eye i
didn't write him a letter but i told him
hey i just need you to know you did a
good job
with me my brother my sister my family
you did a good job
and i watched a guy visibly lose a
couple of hundred pounds right in front
of me
his shoulders dropped and he just said
man thank you it means the world that
you told me that
and i wouldn't trade that conversation
for anything the only thing i wish i had
done it way earlier
and my dad and i have had my just our
disagreements over the years as every
father and son
do but man there was something special
being able to look them in the eye
and tell them i'm grateful for you did a
good job
so john write that letter have that
conversation with them
and if you will honor all the listeners
of this podcast
uh call call me back shoot me an email
back let me know how that conversation
goes
your dad's response i'd love to keep in
touch with you and see how he's doing
and i'd love to see more importantly how
you're doing and how you're going to
continue to live your life
moving forward in the future too